Animated bloopers come from numerous places;
sometimes the animators create their own bloopers
or the voice over artists make mistakes while
filming.
Some bloopers are even planned out to help
promote the film or make the characters more
realistic.
Bloopers from animated films are released
few and far between, which make them even
more of a gem when we get one.
Whether these outtakes are planned or spontaneous
they are still funny and bring an extra dimension
to the characters on screen.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Disney
Bloopers From Animated Films You Love.
Stick around to the end to see some of the
funniest bloopers animation has ever produced.
A Bug’s Life
The first film from the team at Disney and
Pixar to feature spoof bloopers was for a
little film about bugs, A Bug’s Life.
Known as one of their least popular films,
A Bug’s Life was an outstanding and exciting
film to watch.
A lot of this had to do with the creativity
the filmmakers produced including the outtakes
at the end credits.
This film was a follow up to the success of
Toy Story, so it makes sense that they asked
Woody to make a cameo.
He’s all grins in his scene; maybe he was
excited because he had a sequel coming up.
The Lion King
In 1994’s The Lion King the film features
two beloved characters Timon and Pumba played
by Nathan Lane and Ernie Sabella.
They lived by the motto, "hakuna matata,"
which means “no worries” in Swahili.
When Disney released their Diamond Edition
DVD of this film, they added a segment called,
“Bloopers & Outtakes”.
Lane and Sabella are hilarious in the reel
making numerous blunders and flatulence jokes
but the highlight comes when Rafiki drops
Simba in his famous presentation scene.
Hopefully there was a stunt pad below.
Monsters Inc.
We were already provided a great deal of comedy
in 2001’s Monsters Inc. because of stars
Billy Crystal and John Goodman killing it
on screen, but what about the end credits?
The filmmakers added spoof bloopers to their
monster theme film as if the film was actually
filmed in Monstropolis.
Including a monster with tentacles running
the clapper or characters arguing about getting
more film roles.
They also threw in a scene of Rex from the
Toy Story films auditioning for a role in
this film.
If you want more outtakes with the Toy Story
cast stick around because they’re coming
up.
Brave
The animation process is a long and costly
process; many times the animators are developing
techniques they have never done before.
In 2012’s Brave the filmmakers had to animate
Merida’s hair and it was no easy task, it
is made up of 111,700 hairs that were generated
from over 1500 individually sculpted models.
During test footage you can see the complications
they had animating her hair and the complications
of keeping her clothes on during a horseback
ride.
Inside Out
When you fill the roles of an animated film
with comedy actors like Bill Hader, Mindy
Kaling, Lewis Black and Amy Poehler you expect
a good time during production.
When recording the voice over of their animated
characters you can see the cast and filmmakers
were having a blast.
One actor that kept cracking herself up was
Poehler, she spontaneously laughed throughout
her read showing why she was the right choice
for the role of Joy.
No one can be as joyful as Poehler while reading
the lines from this film.
Big Hero 6
Baymax introduces his own gag reel for the
2014 Disney film Big Hero 6.
During production of the film, animators would
make spoof scenes to entertain themselves
and the filmmakers.
These scenes included Baymax flying with a
cat head, a professor dancing in the background
during a fight scene and Baymax being poked
like the Pillsbury Doughboy.
Check out his hat and next time you see Baymax
at Disneyland poke his belly.
Finding Nemo
In the 2003’s Finding Nemo there are numerous
Easter Eggs in the film but when a star from
another animated film shows up and blatantly
swims across the screen is it still an Easter
Egg?
We could say that it is a cameo but when that
person is a monster swimming with a snorkel
we have to say it’s a blooper.
Did Mike Wazowski, from Monsters Inc. swim
onto the wrong movie set and the filmmakers
just left it in for laughs?
Or maybe the filmmakers are hinting at a spinoff
film called, Finding Mike Wazowski?
Toy Story 2
The first sequel to a Pixar film, Toy Story
2 is one of those rare occurrences where the
sequel is just as good or even better than
the original.
The characters all seem to enjoy each other
and these bonus bloopers showcase this delight.
Woody pulled practical jokes on Buzz and Jessie
actually pulled Woody’s string out of his
back.
One of the fan favorite bloopers is Mrs. Potato
Head preparing Mr. Potato Head for his outing.
She kept filling him up with props that he
would have no use for until chattering teeth
take over.
Brother Bear
Brother Bear was disappointing at the box
office but the outtakes were not.
In a way to help promote the film Disney released
a gag reel that showcased the fun the animated
cast had on set.
Including a time when Stitch from Lilo & Stitch
made its way onto the set and ruined a take.
The bears even broke a camera increasing Disney’s
budget, while another cast member relaxed
in a river drinking fruit drinks.
This was all in good fun and was a highlight
of this films production.
Frozen
The chemistry between Kristen Bell & Idina
Menzel is splendid and the filmmakers knew
this.
During recording of their scenes for the 2013
film Frozen, both Bell and Menzel were put
in the same room for recording.
These two actresses loved working together
and we loved hearing them.
At one point Bell’s delivery of a line made
Menzel laugh, she broke character and they
had to redo the scene.
What do you think of our video?
Did we skip over any of your favorite Disney
Bloopers From Animated Films?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos!
Thanks for watching Screen Rant and click
on our next video to enjoy another awesome
list.